[Music]
sometimes on my morning commute to class
or work
while i'm just in my car alone
driving to wherever i have to go
i feel such a strong
overwhelming sense of loneliness
and a feeling that i am
the only one who will ever understand me
and it gets
intense to the point that i start
sobbing and this thought it just occurs
very randomly
so
in the middle of my commute
surrounded by cars
i'm just sobbing
and it gets overwhelming to the point
where i don't even feel human
and then it goes away
but it just keeps happening
and i'm not quite sure what to make of
it
[Music]
so i got a secret that i found out about
the family an uncle of mine had
disappeared in afghanistan and nobody
knows why he had a car he had a business
he was starting he had so many things
going for him but he up and left
he didn't take his keys not his clothes
didn't tell his wife his mom nothing
just left come to start investigating
his brother started telling the family
that he got kidnapped by the taliban or
that he was into something and something
happened to him that was the story that
went around to the females in my family
and one of my cousins told me that just
had gotten back from afghanistan he was
out there and he just had gone back he
had told me about what really happened
he told me for for whatever reason that
the brothers got into an altercation
they got into a fight and
he killed him
he
killed him disappeared him hit his body
from the rest of his family and acted
like nothing happened to this day my mom
my grandma my aunts they all believed
that the taliban took them and
disappeared them
but
it's their brother that
calls them every day talks to them they
send money to them
like somebody that's such a part of
their lives that took another part of
their lives and they don't know that
so
i've always kept that secret from my mom
i think if i told her that would
destroy her but
it's pretty crazy
[Music]
years ago the only reason i continued
living was for other people
[Music]
i still sometimes look
and i'm searching for the reason to keep
living for myself
[Music]
so my secret is that some wearing
sunglasses kind of makes me feel
more secure confident in what i'm saying
um it
is likened to the effect that being on
the internet and being able to just type
to a screen has it's
weird i broke up with my girlfriend with
my glasses on and i don't think i could
have without them
a lot of my coworkers and friends have
this expectation that i'm so sweet and
so nice to people but i don't think i
live up to those expectations because i
actually really don't like people
i prefer being on my own
[Music]
the only time i've ever been hit on at
work
is by male customers in at least their
30s
who think i'm a lady
i'm a man
i'm 19.
it's happened twice
it's always the same co-worker who is
talking to those customers as well and
he comes over and says hey kiefer
and i say what he says those customers
uh they really like you and i say yeah
and he says yeah they think you're a
chick
and i look at him and
and i'm not happy with him
[Music]
at one of my best friend's graduation
parties i hooked up with his aunt like
15 years ago and i've never told anybody
sometimes when i'm walking down the
street i pretend like i'm a drag queen
performing
on stage a really really long stage
[Music]
so a long time ago when i was little my
cousin and i were just kind of bored and
we
decided to play a little uh prank on uh
the neighbor
so we wrote this like letter saying that
we had like kidnapped her daughter
and that she had to pay like
this amount of money and she had to um
like drop it off in like a certain place
and we're like so little like
the letter probably didn't even make
sense but they eventually like they
found it because we left it like on the
door
and they thought it was real so they
called the cops and like it was a big
thing you know they came to us like my
aunt and stuff and we just pretended
like we didn't know but they were like
super scared and they thought something
bad had happened and it was like a big
thing but we never told anybody
[Music]
i told everyone that that speaker was
broken at work
but it was not i just wanted it and
everyone gives me trash
so if i say something is trash then they
give it to me and so that's what
happened to the speaker
at my job
[Music]
okay so when i was younger i used to
have a major
anger issue like i had no control over
it whatsoever
so i used to have this
boyfriend pillow
it was basically like a pillow with just
one arm
bent so it's like
think if if you're wrapping your arm
around someone's shoulder that's how the
pillow was shaped
and i would take my frustration out on
this pillow by
grabbing an actual knife and shanking it
over and over again
let's just say that pillow did not last
a while
i was once diagnosed with a mental
disease that no one thought was curable
i'm perfectly fine today but i've kept
this a secret since there's such a
stigma and i would be treated completely
different if i were to ever reveal that
publicly
[Music]
i
don't really
love my dad i kind of just use him for
rides and money
and just to clarify
he's a terrible person
but
you know
[Music]
i blame myself for my best friend's
death
[Music]
my secret is that
i am a completely uninteresting person
and i have nothing
to
share at all
i really wish i did though
[Music]
so growing up uh i did not have a good
relationship with my mother
always loved her but growing up we would
often uh fight it was a very volatile
relationship a lot of heartache a lot of
anger i think going in both directions
and i remember one time i think maybe i
was 12 or 13 years old we had a very
bitter fight
now some context before i continue my
mother uh
was with my father just for a few years
before she left him he was a very
violent man
very abusive man alcoholic drug user
sexist racist you know just
all the bad things a person could be or
could do
uh going back to my story so uh i'm 12
13 years old
had a big bitter fight
and i said something that haunts me to
this day that i hate it every time i
think about it i said something along
the lines of you know now i see why dad
did all those things to you
so i pretty much said now i see why he
beat you and terrorized you
i apologize i think a day or two
afterwards but to this day decades later
it eats me up in sight just thinking
that something so vile so terrible
could escape my lips
especially given that i love my mother
because as i mentioned growing up we
fought a lot
but i always loved her
and now our relationship is the best
it's ever been
but still every once in a while i'll
think about that fight
and i just feel terrible and i just hope
that she really knows that i truly am
sorry
and that i wish i could take it back
[Music]
hey everyone try here i wanted to say
thank you for watching this episode i am
still selling these sweaters on my
website if you're interested i'll link
in my description i love you guys and
i'll see you next week
[Music]